my one of my favorite animals in the
world is a dolphin
that's my favorite animal
we have so much in common we do yeah did
you tell me but the thing is i took them
uh swimming with dolphins and things
like that but then yeah you were the one
that talked about don't dolphins they
can rape they have secret rape caves do
you know this about dolphins no they
have secret okay alex you might have to
come on the mic for this one because my
brother knows a lot about animals but
they have secret rape caves where they
have been known to take people down
underwater hold them under water and
rape them under water and kill them
are you still impressed with my daughter
alex don't come on alex
that is the weirdest fact
i have ever heard
maybe in the last 10 years
no that's that's the truth during the
metoo movement she was all about she
went to sea world and did
held up picket
signs don't know
yes she said you think harvey
weinstein's bad
you should have met flipping you also
can't go in the ocean or with dolphins
if you're pregnant
because because
what is it is it their sonar radar
whatever it is yeah the radar yeah they
like it can
vibrate so much that it
injures or detaches them the umbilical
cord alex can you please come on the mic
and tell me if i'm right or wrong this
is not true i believe you're right i
believe i believe you 100 so pregnant
women what if a pregnant because i go i
go on
to the beach and you'll see pregnant
women in the ocean are they yeah no no
no up to their knees what'd you say
about pregnant the thing is is they
communicate with like yeah but there is
pretty much they just they're just
interested because they can hear the
baby i know but they poke it first of
all and it's dangerous because they're
interested because and so they can hurt
it but i also heard that their
vibrations when they make that sound i
don't know about and injure the
umbilical cord i don't i haven't looked
into it that much maybe all right enough
about it no no but i i have to say that
sounds
they do travel and they do communicate
with sonar so that makes a lot of sense
to me really yeah a lot of the
the rape and the uh i don't know about
losing your children i don't know what
to do
doesn't make sense
alex isn't the rape truth no don't stop
talking to alex we have an illustrious i
want to make sure i'm spitting facts
here well i i'm sorry no
i just find that stuff i love how you
have a nice relationship with your
brother you were joking it was uh yeah
it was there's no cake
he was joking he said i forgot to tell
you i was joking you mean he made that
off he made that up a couple of years
ago
he made that up a couple of years ago
she shared it with you not only that uh
henry you believed it you believed it
because she started with this arcadian
rhythm hold on and there's nothing you
can't do we have a guest not cool no no
i'm i know now no listen she needs we're
bonding now no you're not bonding we
have the same favorite animal so we're
talking about our favorite animal no
that's true i think this is this how
many people listened
to this yeah
we don't have a listener i don't have a
i don't have a i don't even really have
a podcast i just wanted to spend time
with you you know what i'm i'm down
[Music]
you